this is you you're a twenty-something
ambitious implant from the Midwest
living in San Francisco this is you too
you're a cute 20-something recent
Berkeley grad she swiped right on you're
going on a date but you're on a budget
in the most expensive American city to
live in so how do you have a good time
without spending too much
who said toast can't be romantic
probably someone not living in San
Francisco trouble coffee in the Outer
Sunset serves up a $4 toast that you and
your date are likely to be skeptical
about until that first bite after that
you'll just get preachy about how is
your jam you like her and she likes you
too and you're both okay with cliches
like bison watching at Golden Gate Park
yes the age-old rendezvous tactic
that'll have her laughing at your
attempts to look cute don't be afraid to
actually get thrifty thrift store
shopping on a date is a great way to
play around with looks exert power of
bodily control over one another and
enjoy the flashy zany outcomes if your
style is more modern vintage chic meets
gentrify ER check out the wasteland
thrift store in the Haight
you're not afraid of getting a little
physical a little early in the date
revisit your prepubescent self going
down the slides of Bernal Heights all
you'll need is some cardboard to hold on
to and a good life insurance policy
you want a form film and a cuddle so you
go to the Roxy theater afterwards you
cross the street grab a cream sandwich
maybe some hummus and pita and head on
over to Dolores Park where you can talk
about job insecurities
you don't play games except arcade games
so naturally you take him to the museum
mechanic or the arcade museum and
Fisherman's Wharf it's cute dripping
with nostalgia and all you need are some
quarters and as the night comes to a
close you can test the strength of your
stomachs together by sharing a clam
chowder bread bowl the way clam chowder
was just meant to be
you